[Musique]
attendez moi j'ai entendu à la radio ce
matin on a une chance sur 10 millions de
se faire mordre par une chauve-souris
enragée faut quand même savoir qu'il ya
un gars qui sait sûrement casser le cul
pendant des mois et des mois avec du
matériel et tout pour arriver à la
conclusion suivante on a eu une chance
sur 10 millions de se faire mordre par
une chauve-souris enragée
alors moi je suis pas curieux mais
j'aurais bien quand même savoir comment
il a fait le gars pour déterminer qu'on
avait tous en moyenne une chance sur dix
millions de ses remords
bah oui monsieur bon admettons que le
gars soit très copain avec une bande de
chauve-souris enragée
il est connais depuis longtemps il gère
des paniques et et était dans la merde
et tous m'ont vu à lui doivent tout à
lui cache rien ils ont un degré
d'intimité ensemble mais bon moi je dis
que c'est un peu facile de [ __ ] les
jetons à tout le monde
avec finalement la seule chance qu'on a
de ce fait remords d' un en occultant
volontairement excusez moi du peu
les 9 millions 999 999 autres chance
qu'on a de poste ferme en dhr donc ne
pas mourir dans d'atroces souffrances
bah oui parce que moi je vois j'habite
dans le xème un bon déjà le dixième
c'est un quartier question chauves
souris qui est assez tranquille
reconnaît cj c'est tranquille en plus
j'habite au cinquième sans ascenseur
j'ai dirigé un code à la porte en bas et
un interphone
or la chauve-souris
non mais admettons admettons arrive une
chauve-souris enragée elle allait
arracher la pop un sommet à trifouiller
mon code aller à tfo et elle cherche et
cherche si si monsieur côté sont enragés
cherche comme hama elle cherche et
cherche bon et tombe sur mon code faut
encore qu'elle imite la voix d'un gars
que je connais sinon j'ouvre pomme
bon j'étais un peu bourré la veille je
n'ai pas bien dormi s'est posé la
question
jouve faut qu'elles poussent la porte
c'est grand comme ça une chauve-souris
bon mais admettons et pousse la porte
mais vous allez quand même pas me dire
qu'à va monter les cinq étages à pied
comme ça ça sert à repérer par quels
canaux ingé crois pas je suis contre
honnêtement j'ai groupe façon j'ai fait
mes tâches et d'hommes apporte alors bon
alors il sut le palier
qu'est ce qui prouve qu'à va frapper à
ma porte il ya quatre appartements sur
le palier ouais frappe à ma porte
chez pol pot a jusqu'à maintenant
sheila manifestement c'est moi qui avais
mort d'un lacet yeah i'm a choisi dans
l'immeuble veut plus mode personne
d'autre c'est moi bon ben je vais
jusqu'au bout
jouve qu'est ce qui prouve qu'à va me
sauter tout de suite à la gorge pour me
mordent 10 dont elle est pas un petit
peu fatigué cette chauve-souris depuis
tout ce qu'a fait le tailleur à la
petite soif
robin moi je m'installe de la banquette
jaffa mine d'aller lui chercher un verre
d'eau dans la cuisine
qu'est ce qui m'empêche de revenir avec
un fusil alors est ce qu'elle se méfie
pas c'est quand même d'une bête alors
j'étais au dessus même si jaloux peut
pas elle a peur et puis s envole par la
fenêtre alors que je pense à l'autre
colas il fout les jetons à tout le monde
sait je souris au plus il est dangereux
ce mec là il ma xinchun que pas qu'il y
ait chez moi des qui sait en chauve
souris pour me faire rayonner
[Musique]
je tiens de su parfaitement j'écope
hagen chez moi de grisolles chauve
souris pour me faire rigoler alors
qu'ils arrêtent un autre nom etc ces
chauves souris
j'ai peur de chauves souris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]